did you guys like donda
mark two i only watched like part of the
music video just like the highlights
i don't understand at first i thought
the set was fire okay
house water lit as [ __ ] okay
what do you mean i brought up my phone
before you did no i was looking at the
whole time we're in here editing
isn't that nice
must be nice huh yeah it must be yeah
yeah but no i thought it was fire that
visually was sick um i didn't hear any
of the songs and i didn't hear any song
that was new i just heard all the old
songs no he had a couple new ones on
there i didn't even notice him
i like i didn't hear any clips from it
nothing and then the sound engineers
apparently all got fired
that's what people have been saying they
should they should have they [ __ ] it
up why they [ __ ] up that's right you
look like kanye honestly when connie was
standing there just fuming oh so heated
standing there through his [ __ ]
microphone yeah that's what i look like
every weekend
[Laughter]
um okay so we thought visually it was
very interesting obviously the
performance wasn't incredible there were
some mic issues etc
um what i'm curious about in terms of
his team is like he just fires people
who rehires all the necessary people
yeah i don't even understand handling
all that like he's coming up with these
ideas right
there's no way he knows how to like call
all these different businesses and
execute said ideas running a
stadium-sized show like that is like
insane logistically so who's really
doing all this and who's taking his
ideas and turning them into reality
that's what i'm curious about he has a
chief of staff i know someone that was
on that team like a chief of staff and
then he's got like that's the creative
director that's the fashion person
that's the touring person that uh what
happens when he fires everybody
people waving the wings i don't know and
then does he call new people like i
can't see him doing anything outside of
like
thinking of creative stuff and then just
kind of like spewing them at people and
then they go actually make it happen
yeah that's what i assume it i'm really
curious about those people that can
execute his vision well i think it's
like you know how he's always
name-dropping big icons and fashion and
tech and all of this i'm sure he has
this person that says get me the
meetings with all of those
people on those teams and i think he's
just building up all i mean he just
knows these folks like these like
lighting designers that would do that
show that was stunning and there's
people around him that i assume that
just want to be around him by watching
the kanye dock it's like bro this guy
lifted his whole life i mean grant i
don't know what he's doing in chicago
but like changed his whole life moved to
new york just to follow connie around as
like a nobody producer rapper person
yeah he knows all the virgil blows like
he you just know that he's he's got his
finger there
and anyone would be like i'll [ __ ]
take [ __ ] from kanye for a month to just
work with him i'm just saying i'm very
impressed with execution everybody's got
ideas few people have good ideas even
fewer people have incredible ideas but
executing ideas is hard
and obviously it gets easier
uh as you become more famous right
because you have the funds to do it but
but that's what we saw on the concert
the execution of the audio side was
and he does a lot of stuff rushed i
don't think this show was planned that
far in advance like the tickets just
went on sale the day before
so it's like
that's funny um
yeah so it's like if you're rushing a
show in a [ __ ] arena
something's about to go wrong i'm
surprised it looked as good as it did
yeah
plus the live stream component like live
switching you have basically like a
whole like
tv production arm that's like manning
all the cams and live streaming and
switching everything to all the
different platforms it was on instagram
it was on stemplayer.com it was on
amazon music it was it was in movie
theaters yeah he set up a company
he is a creative agency he set up a
creative agency for this reason and then
you start just adding these he's been
planning this because he's spending a
ton of money i mean literally he outed
one of the guys on instagram for
spending too much money yeah person was
probably like top in his field running
as [ __ ] ciao yeah yeah he at the rate
and pace that he's going he he's
spending crazy amount of money so he's
just blowing crazy
he's not going into like contract
negotiation with these different vendors
and trying to fight let me try to kind
of deal with this
we need this how much is it sure yeah
got you okay that makes a little bit
more sense but i i don't know maybe i'm
alone in this but aren't you guys
impressed that like yeah it can be done
yeah like i don't know to me yeah but he
also just has the clout money and like
legacy just to
speak things into existence and they get
done yeah and that's i think that's the
biggest part because
without the clout no one's going to take
that let's go life and then go do it
yeah yeah yeah i mean we have a buddy of
ours kid super who uh was telling me he
went he was telling us that he went to
work with him for a couple weeks
and like he said it was it was well he
was a big fan of kanye i wonder if we
can even share this yeah i'm sure we can
but he was like it was dope like
he just like
said hey go cook up some cool stuff
you have ideas come on hit me with ideas
like it wasn't an actual structured job
but he also did say he fired the whole
team while he was there oh wow yeah
including the person who was supposed to
pay him
oh wow yeah so he didn't get paid i was
like did you get paid he's like uh that
guy got fired
yeah wow and i'm sure he could hit up
the new person or whatever it was but
like
i don't know i'm just so fascinated with
like who's running that just from
building this like all of us building
this
the organization
and like the structure and that kind of
stuff
that is the most foreign stuff for me
like it's easy to get a bunch of us here
and like work on a group project that's
easy that's fun then you start to grow
it beyond the team and that gets
difficult
just finding the right people hiring
people like he got over this hump where
he just fires everybody yeah
that's [ __ ] that's you're you're
asking someone to commit their life
change something like those people he
fired probably gave up everything yeah
yeah so go work for him but he's got the
cloud that you could just call up
someone and be like yo kanye west wants
me to go chicago to work on this thing
i'm gone but don't you care a little
about them their families like
i know they're just like
that's a different level of of
narcissism like where it's just like
whatever it takes to get me to do my
thing and i don't care
like matter of fact if you [ __ ] it up
that's on you and all those people were
trying their best
but like and they ultimately they [ __ ]
it up don't get me wrong i'm just saying
like
oof no like those people that can do
that like the people that work for those
corporations and they lay off 30 000
people on a monday yeah this guy the the
guy that did it on zoom
like however many people like 2000
people are just like so well we're
terminating this whole department yeah
and they're all just like
looking at [ __ ] max they can't afford
like [ __ ]
they like laid off 28
100 employees and just gave them a free
subscription
yeah yeah you're gonna have some extra
time i don't know if it was just that
but that was like a product yeah or
whatever yeah that's i mean like we'll
get back to donna saying but like that's
a tricky thing about peloton like
anybody who's used peloton acknowledges
it's awesome mm-hmm like you used to
work out peloton you're still doing
peloton no i actually sold them
interesting
in solidarity
with the working class yeah exactly
i don't know i thought it was phenomenal
i i think the organization of it the
classes of it the motivation i mean i'm
fortunate enough where i get to like
work out with a person yeah but if i
couldn't like being able to have that
access which is great
it's one of those things where it's like
this is a ceo problem not a
actual business product and that's what
the ceo is the one that came in and
fired folks
yeah i don't know if it's a ceo probably
go go i think it was it was hype so so
many people bought it early we're buying
an over priced piece of
equipment like we know it's overpriced
and then eventually after having it a
while it's like
this is good it runs great but it
it's too expensive for what it is
you can get an exercise bike attach an
ipad to it and like it's a fraction of
the price well that's what they also
offer like for me it wasn't really the
bikes it was the workout classes i would
just put my phone up on a treadmill on
the road and then do the whole class
from the traffic that's like 40 a month
for yeah those classes are less added
and more expensive and people might be
financing the bike but actually
the when they pitched and got their
initial investment they sold it not as a
bike company it was literally one of the
old spinning bikes with an ipad attached
and says this is a multi-billion dollar
content uh media company so that's what
like the new pelotons the the screen
turns around so it can be for the floor
exercises yeah i had that yeah the
overpriced treadmill that andrew almost
got eaten by that doesn't make sense i
don't know how many people are buying 4
000 no but even the bike i had the bike
that turned or i had the bike that
turned it was 28 when i first got you
didn't buy the 60 amazon piece that just
let you know the version one no loser
that one didn't have beyonce i'm not
going to get that
point come on bro that's a good ass
point but
like a few months later it was down to
1900.
so the price of the bike kept dropping
and now we're realizing like oh
that much so now do you think it's
possible that
the value of the company like many
companies was inflated because of the
pandemic absolutely and then they built
their business and expectations on that
inflatable on that inflated price
so now we're seeing a like regression to
the mean like where the actual true
value is for the company but they're
freaking out like something's wrong and
it's like fam you were never that
lucrative yeah like maybe you would grow
to that one day but of course people are
going to go on pedal time when they're
literally can't leave their house it's
illegal to go to the gym illegal to go
to the gym and
the second gyms open up you know we're
gonna want it extra we're back in the
gym we're working out we're realizing
how much these classes are great we're
going to our trainer etc that's going to
cool off too yeah yeah so these gyms are
popping now as well they're going to get
that 30
they're going to get the 30 cent boost
where the dip came for peloton and these
other maybe like workout uh
other kind of like workout exercise apps
etc
that's gonna come back down and then
maybe peloton comes back up
you're just not as high as as it was
yeah
like evaluation of what their products
and companies get 100 because it's
[ __ ] like if you got bread it is
[ __ ] convenient to just have that
[ __ ] right there you have 30 minutes you
can go in and know there's a 30 minute
workout yeah like it dude yeah it was
convenient it was fire i loved it it
just once [ __ ] started opening up it's
like like that gym still better yeah it
is better yeah being with a person is a
hundred percent better
but this convenience is valuable yeah
yeah
okay but on kanye you should watch the
doc yeah i gotta watch it i gotta watch
it it's a cool like cultural moment like
that he's like putting on all this [ __ ]
like the stem player the music video and
then he has like the doc that's gonna
drop in like multiple parts i think over
time like as the episodes drop there's
going to be more things that are
revealed that i think will like drive
combo and like eyeballs yeah that i just
think is like will be an interesting
moment to be
experiencing in real time okay i'll make
sure
this is going to be his jordan doc
that is big this is hoop dreams up this
is a different story
but i think it changes people's
perception
no that's what i'm saying but go back
and then jordan did i mean i don't know
if this was good for jordan that's my
point i don't know if it'll be good for
kanye oh it's really that honest the
first one the first episode is amazing
but it's like i could see it it's dark
but it is honest though in the sense
that it's like yo this is a kid from
chicago like this is his relationship
with his mom like it feels vulnerable
and if it continues to be that
vulnerable then it would reflect the
truth of his character which is both
good and bad yes
so i think at
the end of the day it will be good for
him because people will understand his
outburst a little bit more yeah probably
and i think the jordan dock was good for
jordan because he had a whole generation
that didn't know how great he was right
so even though we saw some [ __ ] sides
of him it's like at the end of the day
it was uh i wonder if jordan and maybe
kanye are okay with that because they
understand what it takes to be great
yeah so they're like yeah this is the
cost yeah well you think you're just a
sweetheart like i'm not a politician
yeah right like they're going i'm a
basketball player i'm an entertainer in
order to do this at the highest level
it requires sacrifices i'm not here to
be liked by everybody yeah where a
politician something like that coming
out it would be absolutely devastating
yeah jordan still has that drive in him
like you said at the all-star game he
told me
[Music]
do you know when this kanye dock ends
because if it's this guy cootie that was
following him forever no when in his
career journey
because if it's ending before he's even
with the kardashians or before he went a
little kooky this is only gonna make him
look spectacular yeah we don't know oh
yeah it's the glory days of kanye's the
director is that guy that's been with
him since like yeah he's been waiting
early
so that's all hoop dreams and that's all
phenomenal everyone's going to be a fan
of copyright it's just also excellent
like in the way documentary filmmaking
is like creating make me feel however
the modern kanye does not speak on this
first episode this is not him commenting
this is literally just voice over and
archival from the perspective of this
kind of phone i mean he speaks a little
and his the way he talks is so different
like did you notice that like he's
talking like old kanye speaks yeah like
yeah yeah exactly what do you mean by
that he just sounds like an 18 year old
kid that grew up in chicago
like he sounds like he speaks with like
a chicago dialect like he's speaking
like like he it's interesting because
you see the influence of like
living in chicago but also having like
academic parents yeah and like how he's
trying to deal with that as like a
person i don't know it's just really
interesting he also had a retainer in
his mouth the whole time until the
accident put a [ __ ] bar through his
mouth yeah so he had a retainer yeah
before
before the accident yeah
you think that accident now that we know
like the effects of cte and that kind of
stuff you think the accident has done
something to his mental health i think
it was a jaw break but did it break do
it break your jaw you got to create
enough force to crack your jaw your
brain is going to shake in your skull
right if you're already predisposed to
mental health issues like having cte can
perpetuate and like exacerbate that is
that right i think so yeah if you're
predisposed to that type of thing like
head trauma can because some people get
a bunch of [ __ ] get a bunch of head
injuries and like the encephalopathy
doesn't actually manifest the same way i
think also the death of his mother that
we all i think you just made that [ __ ]
up
i think you just made that
encyclopedia or something like that
that's that's what that's the end part
that's the e no yeah that's when your
head turns to swiss cheese
that's not what cte stands for oh
i thought it did no i thought i said
chronic traumatic encephalopathy
but what does it actually mean chinese
terrorism
encephalopathy
yeah we always talk about that with
antonio brown we talk about those with
these athletes
i wonder if there's something to happen
i mean that's like a huge accident we're
talking about yeah they cover the next
episode i don't actually know how bad it
was massive brain damage probably what
up people you just watched a clip from
our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
you